[Music]
thank you
we are determined to do what we can to
address the humanitarian needs of the
Syrian people we have a partner in the
form of ngos on the ground who are
providing humanitarian support
foreign
has primarily affected the northern part
of Syria many areas that contested many
areas are under opposition control it is
going to be a challenge to get in there
this is a country that has suffered 11
years of work infrastructure is damaged
[Music]
foreign
it is very important to put all politics
aside look at this as a strictly
humanitarian issue it is about saving
lives so we are pushing all we can to
support getting that Aid into all the
areas where it's needed